weeks Arthur the outbreak of xenophobic
violence the city center of Johannesburg
still shows the signs of a fractured
city every single one of these
burned-out shops were once owned by
migrants can see franzen on the roof the
adt the security company actually
extinguish the fire because they wanted
to bend the entire shop on that night
and they said the foreigners were taking
the jobs was it like is a republic it
was like almost 300 people so the lagoon
shot-by-shot the retargeting shops that
were owned by foreigners this part of
town is ravaged by drugs alcohol and
despair over unemployment among South
Africans so kill them now why I don't
work 9 i'm seeing but this foreigners is
a check the wiki and it takes a small
money at the compound in order to
understand the impact of the violence we
are visiting yeovil a neighborhood which
is largely run by foreigners roughly
5,000 people left the country roughly we
still have in kwazulu-natal for instance
we still have people who are living in
comes because they're not entered
reintegrated in the community so
unfortunately the past few weeks towards
where we're very tense many South
Africans are feeling embarrassed over
what happened to their neighbors
it's not good it's not right urac you
are the same so there's no need a people
to not kill a lot of people I'm from
Nigeria i've been here since three years
do you feel safe in South Africa still
yeah if you save in South Africa you saw
what happened with all the scene of
phobic attacks we do did you not get
scared I was Ted what's I know what
isn't going true but other African
countries have reacted fiercely to the
violence with Nigeria threatening to
close down south african shops in
Nigeria and Mozambique warning its
citizens not to go there anymore as a
lot to lose if all migrant move out of
South Africa is not possible because
South Africa itself cannot imagine if
you are strong is because of others you
cannot be strong buy your own Ubuntu I
am because others are is after all the
most you saying in the country that used
to proudly call itself the rainbow
nation